they gathered from early evening in the
square outside the European Parliament
almost all of them here pro EU but was
it to be their night inside the chamber
the dust settled quickly as projections
came in fragmentation was the word of
the night the dominance of the big
center left and center-right groupings
hit hard not though by the pan
continental nationalists Euroskeptic
surged some had predicted but in large
part by liberal pro europe parties for
the first time in 40 years since the
first elections in 1979 of European
Parliament the to classical parties
socialists and conservatives will no
longer have a majority so a good night
for the green this is a good night it is
a good night excellent night it wasn't
on the top of my expectation so I'd said
the worst case 50 best case 70 in
Strozier 217 edited then it is 250 still
in the few countries where nationalists
and he Brussels forces are strong so too
were their results in France nationalist
marine lepen beat president macrons
party but given the hard time he's had
in recent months it could have been
worse for him italy's right-wing
interior minister was thrilled his party
calling for fundamental reform in
brussels topped the italian polls not
only as the league the first party in
Italy but marine lepen is the first
party in France in the UK Nigel Faraj is
first so Italy France England it's the
sign of a Europe that is changing so the
dominance of the to traditional centrist
parties has given way to a boost for
smaller ones some Euroskeptic but most
not and the turnout 50.5% is a record
the central message then is that voters
mostly don't necessarily want less
Europe but they do want change there is
something else though that will surely
focus many many Minds here in Brussels
Nigel Faraj a thorn in so many sides in
this chamber a man who's tried to
dismantle the EU from within his party
could now be one of the largest national
parties
in this chamber for brexit the louder
the noise mr. Faraj and his party make
here the less likely it is that the EU
will grant another extension come
October marks Doan Sky News in Brussels